Are Anna and Josh dating?
Oh, thank you.
Well, they've been hanging out together a lot recently.
I'd ship them.
Yeah, but like, are they "together" together?
Why?
Are you interested?
No, I'm just wondering.
Oh, you got like some eyebrow lash right there.
Facebook.
Alright, no relationship status.
Trying to keep things all on private.
We need like pictures.
Look, their shoulders are almost touching in this one!
They are touching!
So lucky!
She tweeted, "'Cause I give you all of me, and you give me all of you, oh oh".
She must be in love.
She has to be!
Why do they all put their tweets on private?
That doesn't make any sense.
Well it's probably so that creepers like you can't stalk them.